problema número 232 si 1 / x 1 / x 1 es
igual a 1 / x 4
entonces x podría ser igual a
bueno aquí nos podríamos ver tentados a
invertir todas estas fracciones pero no
podemos hacer esto aún antes hay que
sumar estas dos fracciones vamos a hacer
lo vamos a encontrar el común
denominador de esto que es x por x +
zona y ahora este 1 lo multiplicamos por
x + 1 para que se conserve esta
proporción me queda aquí x + 1 - y aquí
esto tengo que multiplicarlo por x para
que se mantenga esa proporción acá me
queda menos x más x menos x es 0 me va a
quedar 1 entre x x x mazón vamos a
factorizar esto me queda x x x x
cuadrada x x una x unas x 11 / todo esto
y bueno todo esto que hicimos fue para
esta parte y ahora podemos usar esto que
acabamos de hacer 1 / x cuadrada + x y
desde un inicio nos dicen que esto es
igual a 1 / x + 4
ahora si podemos invertir ambos lados de
esta igualdad para que nos quede x
cuadrada más x igual a x 4 restamos x en
ambos lados se van estas 2 me va a
quedar x cuadrada igual a 4 por lo que x
es igual a raíz cuadrada de 4 que es 2
puede ser más o menos 2 y la opción c es
menos 2 por lo que esta es nuestra
opción correcta se siguiente problema
problema número 233 tenemos un medio a
la menos 314 a la menos 2 y un sexto a
la menos 1 y viendo las opciones todas
están en términos de un medio elevado
alguna potencia
vamos a dejarlo de esta manera este ya
está a un medio esto lo dejamos igual un
medio elevado a la menos 3 este de un
cuarto es igual a tener
al cuadrado y esto que es un cuarto todo
esto elevado a la menos 2 y 1 entre 16
es lo mismo que tener un medio elevado a
la cuarta potencia eso es uno entre 16 y
todo esto elevado a la menos 1 y
apliquemos las reglas de los exponentes
si no saben cuáles son los invito a ver
los vídeos que hay en caracas al
respecto esto es igual a tener un medio
a la menos 3 este no cambia por cuando
tenemos estos exponentes de exponentes
lo que hacemos es multiplicar 2 por
menos 2 es igual a menos 4 entonces es
un medio a la menos 4 por un medio 4 por
menos uno menos 4 y ahora que tenemos la
misma base con los exponentes lo que
vamos a hacer es sumar los menos tres
menos cuatro menos cuatro es igual a
menos 11 s es igual a 1 entre 2 a la
menos 11
es mi opción de siguiente problema
234 un contenedor grande se llena con
fichas de colores rojo amarillo verde y
azul que valen respectivamente 7 5 3 y 2
puntos cada una cierto número de fichas
se retiran del contenedor si el producto
de los puntos de las fichas que se
retiraron es de 147.000 cuantas fichas
rojas se quitaron bueno esto está
bastante interesante si se fijan estos
números de acá todos estos son números
primos podemos saber qué cantidad hay de
un número primo en cierta cantidad al
hacer una factorización prima y se
sorprenderán de lo rápido que disminuye
el número comenzamos con nuestra
cantidad original de
147.000 si esto lo divido entre 3 de
hecho vamos a hacer la operación acá con
un lado
147 aquí omito los 3 ceros para hacer la
división más rápido entre 3
esto es igual 3 por 4 12 14 menos 12 2
bajamos el 7 9 por 3 27 27 menos 27 es
igual a cero y aquí bueno agregamos los
ceros que quitamos de la cantidad es 49
mil esto
3 por 49.000 a quien notamos esta
cantidad ahora este 49 mil lo puedo
dividir entre 77 por 7 49 entonces es 7
por 7 mil esto por esto me da esta
cantidad ok ahora este 7 lo puedo
dividir también entre 7 y aquí me queda
mil 7 por mil siete mil y así puedo
seguir pero para no perder tiempo vamos
a fijarnos en el color que nos piden el
calor que nos piden es el rojo y las
rojas valen 7 así que aquí veamos ya no
hay más elementos que puedan factorizar
con 7 este lo puedo factorizar con 5 por
205 por 210 estos son 1200 lo puedo
dividir entre 2 me queda 100 y bueno
aquí puedo seguirlo pero creo que ya no
hay más factores de 7 que es el color
rojo así que el 7 cabe exactamente dos
veces dentro del 147 mil por lo que se
sacaron dos cuentas rojas
es la opción de siguiente problema
235 si 2 / 12 / es igual a 1 cuál es el
valor de ella vamos a multiplicar ambos
lados por 1 entre 2 me va a quedar 2
igual a 1 + 2 / le restó 1 en ambos
lados me queda que uno es igual a 2
entre ella y de entrada qué valor debe
tener para que toda esta fracción es
igual a uno entero pues debe ser igual a
2 y es igual a 2 y es mi opción de aquí
en nuestros problemas hay que hacerlo
rápido porque vamos contrarreloj veamos
el siguiente problema problema número
236 si a b c son números enteros
positivos consecutivos es decir va uno
detrás del otro cuáles de las siguientes
son verdaderas de estas opciones si son
consecutivos quiere decir que a es menor
que b y b es menor que se eso también lo
podemos expresar como que a
vale a ver es igual a 1 y c es igual a
más 2 y también es igual a b 1
veamos 1 esta se cumple de hecho
acabamos de verlo aquí se es igual a a
más 2 quiere decir que la diferencia
entre a y c desde 2 se menos a es igual
a 2 esta se cumple a por b porsche
espacio en lugar de resolver esto
álgebra dicamente vamos a analizarlo de
estos tres números consecutivos 1 al
menos al menos uno siempre va a ser paz
y al multiplicarse por los otros dos
números el resultado siempre será paz
siempre que haya un 2 involucrado con un
factor en una multiplicación el
resultado va a ser paz
así que ésta también es correcta la
tercera
digamos que sustituimos esto por estos
valores de aquí
más ve que ves uno más uno más sé que es
dos más dos entre tres simplificamos
esto esto es más jamás nada más esto es
a más uno más dos son tres entre tres
pues esto factor izamos el tres me queda
tres tercios de a más uno y esto es uno
por lo que me queda a mayor al más uno
es un entero así que también se cumple
es más éste a más uno va a ser igual a b
porque ve es amazon así que esto también
se cuenta las tres opciones se cumplen y
esto es mi opción y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo